hello everyone and welcome to a really
interesting game from round six
of the eleven dungeon tournament uh that
usually takes place in china but uh due
to the
uh well the situation in the world uh it
is being played online and it's uh
it's a rapid games 15 minutes per player
and i think there is some increment uh
let me just check real quickly
uh yeah with a 10 uh 10 second increment
from move one so it's a game
between two of the candidates of the
2020 candidates tournament uh that uh
well i never continued uh being learned
in the anishigiri
and it features a most interesting
moment uh in the game so without further
ado let's check it out and see what's
happening here and
the previous edition in 2019 uh was won
by richard
rapport who is also playing in this
tournament uh however ding was not
playing in
the 2019 edition ending is a very strong
player if you've
if you've heard of him uh however ding
lost a game in round one to
last year's winner richard rapport and
now well it's very interesting to see
what will what happens at the top
uh but this is another game so let's uh
let's focus on that so
ding with the white pieces opens with c4
he goes for the english opening
and the uh gear replies with knight to
f6 we have knight to f3 e6 and now
g3 now going uh for this uh sort of uh
uh well after d5 we have a sort of a
neo-catalan defense uh we have bishop to
g2 and bishop to e7 we have castles
castles
uh there are countless games in the
database featuring this line we have
d4 and now d captures on c4 and now
uh you could go for knight to e5 this is
very popular queen a4 is very popular
but
dingu goes queen to c2 and this is the
absolute main idea here
we have a6 uh and now uh you might think
okay but why not to defend the pawn uh
directly with uh with b5 well it's
similar to
a lot of openings for example in the
queen's gambit accepted where
black will capture on c4 and defending
that pawn will
lead to a very early uh early end for
for black although there are some lines
this is not one of them
although you could try it it's uh it's
been played but
not not with much success so here
instead a6
uh and the a4 now guarding the b5 pawn
so now it
wouldn't really make sense to push b5
because after captures and captures the
the rook would be hanging
so uh we have bishop to d7 uh preparing
to shift the bishop over to c6 the
counter being strong bishop on g2
and now queen captures on c4 ding
finally recaptures that pawn with bishop
to c6 and now
bishop to f4 and here gary goes bishop
to d6 so this has all been played before
and here
uh the popular moves are either queen to
c1 guarding the bishop or just moving
the bishop to g5 to
to pin the knight however here ding goes
bishop to e3
and it is a new move in the position so
already as of movie 11 we have a
completely new game
and it's a weird looking move it
prevents your epon from being
developed but as we often say on this
channel
if it works uh why not so let's see if
it actually works uh
gary continues with h6 and now knights
to c3
dean continues development we have queen
to e7 gary does the same and now
knight to e5 an excellent square for the
knight also offering a trade
of light square bishops so here gary
accepts we have captures captures and
knight beat d7 continuing development
uh and here uh ding trades we have
knight captures on d7 queen captures and
now
rook f2d1 so this whole bishop e2 pawn
action is still happening uh no way for
for white to do anything about it and
here
queen back to e7 uh preparing to bring
the rook over to d8 we have
d5 and now well you can capture and push
e5 gary first decides to bring
the rook to e8 and now after rook 8 to
c1
we now have a capture on d5 so captures
and captures captures and of course
rook captures uh it doesn't really
matter if a queen captures a rook
captures if gary wants he can always
trade queens with queen to e4 check so
here
uh ding played rook captures and now
giri of course went for the queen trade
queen e4 check we have captures captures
uh and now b3 defending that a4 pawn we
have rook
8 to e8 gary doubles up on the e file
and now king to
f3 uh we have uh rook 4 to e6
uh just sorry rook 4 back to e6 and just
uh
strengthening his position and now comes
rook to c4 and here
you can see that the position is uh
pretty much
equal uh one difference is that white
has four points on the queen uh king
side uh black has three
whereas black has an advantage uh on the
queen side three against two but other
than that
two rooks each and a bishop each so
let's see how the game continues
giri offers uh to trade off for one more
pair of rooks so
rook captures bishop captures and now
rook to b4 dean goes after the b7 pawn
and the geary defends it just b6 we have
rook back to c4
putting pressure on this pawn for the
moment there is not much you can do
about it
and rook to e6 now now just uh
bring the rook to the sixth rank to help
out with the defense
we have h4 by ding and now h5 by giri
uh we have bishop to f4 now if the
bishop moves then the
of course uh the the c7 pawn becomes
very weak
so here c5 and now uh ding just trades
we have captures captures and now
rook to e4 offering a trade of rooks and
as ding's king is a lot more active
you do not want to trade rooks here for
example if captures and captures then
white is just winning his king is is too
active it doesn't really matter what
black plays
we can even show this in different color
arrows for example black goes here white
goes here and then you cannot go here
so you'd have to go somewhere else let's
say here and then white just starts
gobbling up
pawns so instead you could try something
like b5 to trade off all of the pawns on
the queen side but the white will ignore
you for example a5 and now after c4
just captures captures king d4 you're
gonna grab that pawn you're you're gonna
grab that pawn and it's an
it's a very easy win for white so here
after rookie
four we have rook to f5 check by geary
king to e3
and now this is the i think the critical
moment of the
of the game uh there are there there is
a lot to be said about this game from
this point uh onwards
but you you'll see what i mean by this
that this is the critical
point uh moment of the game so feel free
to pause the video and uh
figure out what you would play for black
here while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on improving the
position of your king
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show king the f8
uh pretty much solves all of black's
problems as all of these squares are now
covered and white doesn't have a way of
bringing the rook into the game or for
for that matter through the d
file however here gary played b5 and
this
gave ding a lot of a lot of uh well
uh options for how to continue the game
so here
uh ding went immediately for rookie
eight check king to h7 now black's king
is even less active
and now rook to a8 he goes after the the
a6 pawn
we have first rookie five check uh going
after d2 pawn if the white king attacks
the rook so king back to d2 and now rook
to d5 check
king to c3 uh ding brings the king over
to the queen side
and now comes rook to d6 defending the
a6 pawn you could also try something
like captures captures and rook f
e5 or f5 going after uh
after the pawns here but uh that's uh
that would be an entirely different game
here
uh gary went for rook to d6 he decided
to defend the a6 pawn this way
but now captures on b5 with captures and
rook to
uh to b8 now here ding goes after the b5
pawn
so b for chuck and king to c4 and now
this is a a permanently weak pawn
and although uh giri doesn't lose any
pawn so he will not be down material
uh it will be a problem for him rook to
d2 and now
king captures on c5 we have rook capture
to king captures on b4 and now uh sorry
not king
rook captures on b4 uh and now a rook
captures an f2 so here as you can see
the material on the board is equal
however dink has a past pawn uh on b3
uh whereas geary doesn't he he can
create a pass pawn
at some point but for the moment he
still doesn't have any so here
rook to f4 offering a rook trade of
course uh
white cannot uh black cannot accept this
as this is not completely winning white
just pushes the pawn and wins the game
so here instead we have rook to c2 with
check another possibility for geary was
rook to g2 going after this pawn
but then we get rook to f3 and it's a
very very weird
weird position if g5 going after the
pawn then white starts pushing with b4
and it's hard to say if uh if this can
be played uh so here instead
guillory went to rook the c2 with check
rook to c4 defending and only now rook
to g2 going after the pawn
here being defense rook to c3 and now
g5 gary starts pushing those pawns on
the king's side we have b4
and now king to g6 we have b5 and now
king to f5 so both players trying to
trying to
uh uh being pushing his past pawn and
geary trying to create a pass pawn
so here b6 and now g captures on h4
g captures on h4 and now rook to b2 gary
puts a rook behind the pass pawn
as you always should and now he also has
created a past f pawn so here
rook c4 not allowing the king to
approach this pawn
so gary cannot create two pass pawns
because if you're not careful if you
just continue pushing your pawn
at some point uh gary might give up the
rook for for this spawn and then uh with
two past pawns he might actually have
drawing chances there
or maybe even winning it depends on the
position so here
king e5 by black and now king to c6 uh
here we have f5 uh ding's plan is of
course very simple he just wants to play
rook c5 rook b5
cut off the black rooks uh defense of
the b-pawn and then push the pawn to
victory
so here f5 by giri and now um ding says
okay i still have time
upon the b7 and now there's the actual
thread of rook c5
check and then playing rogue b5 and then
it's just game for example if f4
check you're going to play king e4 rogue
b5 the king no longer defends the pawn
and after let's say one check next move
white brings the queen and wins the game
so here uh we have rook captures on b7
uh this has to be played otherwise
you're just lost uh you're lost either
way but it has to be played
king captures on b7 and here f4 uh we
rook the c5 with chuck king to e4 and
now
the ninjas played rook captures on h5
and he was in this position on
54 that uh on each gear resigned the
game and a
wonderful victory for for ding liran in
round six of the dungeon
uh opened a closed tournament uh the
11th edition and here
as there are a lot more people uh
joining chess and starting to to play
chess we're just gonna quickly show uh
why white is completely winning here uh
after black starts pushing his pawn f3
white will just make room to start
pushing his own pawn
and at some point you can give up your
own rook for this pawn and your pawn
will win for example
f2 rook f8 you're gonna play king e3 to
defend your pawn but then
white just starts pushing his pawn it's
a very simple win
king e2 h6 and now of course once you
bring the queen into the game white will
give up the rook and then
queen his pawn and a queen and king will
of course defeat the lone black king
uh in case you were wondering so if you
if you let uh
an engine uh let's say a decent engine
crunch this position to let's say
uh to a depth of maybe uh
70 or something like that 60 70 uh there
are probably
a lot of a lot of positions where uh
you know we could have reached the point
of no return
uh but i think this is actually uh that
position here after this rook to f5
check king to e3 and now missing missing
to play the king to f8
move because after this uh it really
doesn't doesn't feel like white can
hope for for anything you just cut off
the the white rook uh
you know the squares completely and
that's just it by playing b5 instead and
allowing this rook to
check geary allowed the ding uh well uh
this game to even uh turn into a game
because if uh
like i said if king of f8 this is now a
draw and it's uh especially for geary
it's very very weird to
uh you know not miss something like this
unless giri did not want to draw
unless gary wanted to create some chaos
on the board and go for a win then
uh i'm pretty sure that's why why he
didn't play king to f8
but you know in case you were wondering
this is uh just the
just the the the most natural move here
but yeah like i said
maybe gary was uh trying trying to get a
win here so maybe he played it uh
the way he did uh but yeah a really
really uh
you know uh instructive endgame and uh
i hope you guys enjoyed that as well we
don't cover all that many end games
but uh you know when we do they are
they're most mostly instructive
uh so yeah that's uh that's the game i
do hope you guys enjoyed it
we might show a few more games from this
tournament i actually did not know it
was even happening so
that's why i'm only showing the first
game now after seven rounds have been
completed
uh but we'll see how it goes uh i would
like to thank uh adrian sabane
donald swanson joey uh
and claire and kiran for contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga yes we will
continue it at some point
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day